und wir schauen auf einen dramatischen
Anstieg der illegalen Navigation an der
deutschen Grenze jetzt schlägt Sachsens
Innenminister Armin Schuster Alarm
erwarnt der Zustrom der sei bald kaum
noch zu bewältigen
illegale Migration an der deutschen
Grenze die Zahlen steigen wieder
Sachsens Innenminister Armin Schuster
warnt in Bild der Migrationsdruck nimmt
zu in einigen Bundesländern werden erste
Turnhallen wegen der Unterbringung von
Flüchtlingen geschlossen in Sachsen
verschärft sich die Situation Grund ist
die Migration über die Balkanroute und
Tschechien 900
illegale Grenzübertritte in nur einer
Woche zehntausende Kriegsflüchtlinge aus
der Ukraine hat Sachsen bislang
aufgenommen jetzt nimmt auch die Zahl
der Asylbewerber aus anderen Ländern
wieder zu
hauptherkunftsländer Syrien Türkei
Venezuela und Afghanistan natürlich
setzen wir waren auf einen sicheren
Schengen Außengrenzen Schutz der nur
Sinn macht das muss man klar sagen der
nur Sinn macht wenn wir an dieser
Außengrenze auch Asylverfahren betreiben
mit
Zurückweisungen derer die keinen
asylschutz bekommen können und auch
EU-Kommissionspräsidenten Ursula von der
Leyen fordert Kontrollmechanismen
bei aller europäischen Entschlossenheit
und Solidarität in der Ukraine Krise
fehlt es an einer Migrationsdebatte
unsere Reaktion gegenüber ukrainischen
Flüchtlingen darf keine Ausnahme sein
wir brauchen Solidarität aber
gleichzeitig auch eine effektive
Kontrolle unserer Außengrenzen die in
Einklang steht mit Respekt und
Menschenrechten
die Großstädte in Sachsen sie wappnen
sich bereits für eine steigende Zahl an
Asylbewerbern und suchen dringend
Unterbringungsmöglichkeiten
das bundesweite Verteilsystem sei nicht
mehr funktionsfähig sagt Armin Schuster
12 Bundesländer haben sich mittlerweile
aus dem Verteilsystem abgemeldet
darunter auch Sachsen
den Innenminister fordert jetzt die
Bundesregierung zum Handeln auf sonst
sei der Flüchtlingsstrom bald kaum noch
zu bewältigen
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt verbunden mit Manuel
Ostermann stellvertretender
Bundesvorsitzender der Deutschen
Polizeigewerkschaft guten Tag Herr
Ostermann sie haben einen Brief an
bundesinnenministerin Nancy Faeser
geschrieben und haben darin das
Flüchtlingsproblem angesprochen den
Flüchtlingszustrom warum
ja das ist völlig korrekt wir haben die
Ministerin darauf hingewiesen und
deutlich gemacht wo die Problematiken
liegen denn wir sagen das schon seit
Monaten dass wir eine Notifizierung der
binnengrenze brauchen um stationäre
temporärstationäre Grenzkontrollen
vollziehen zu können um der
migrationslager überhaupt Herz zu werden
wissen Sie die migrationszahlen schießen
durch die Decke im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes wir haben in der Grenze zu
Tschechei 200% Anstieg und zu Polen 240
Prozent wie lange will man denn noch
tatenlos zugucken bis das Kind dann im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes im Brunnen
gefallen ist und genau darum ging es in
unserem Schreiben an die Ministerin und
bis zum heutigen Tag müssen wir
feststellen es ist leider überhaupt
nichts passiert also sie fühlen sich da
sicherlich auch im Stich gelassen nehmen
Sie uns einmal mit welche Menschen
kommen derzeit strömen derzeit dort zur
Grenze und welche Lösungen sind nötig
damit man das kontrollieren kann damit
man aber auch den Menschen die Hilfe
brauchen diese auch anbieten kann
ja also wir reden hier von den Zahlen
die ich gerade genannt habe ausdrücklich
nicht von
Migrationsbewegungen mit Ukraine Bezug
sondern das sind Menschen aus
Afghanistan darüber aus der Türkei
unterschiedlicher Nationalitäten also
Drittstaatsangehörige das hat zwei
Gründe einmal Präsident Erdogan treibt
die Syrer die sogenannte Sicherheitszone
zurück wo ca 70.000 Menschen hat
türkisch syrischen grenzen sich
mobilisieren und sich auf dem Weg nach
Europa machen und zum anderen hat
Serbien für über 100 Staaten die
Visumpflicht ausgesetzt darunter auch
zum Beispiel Afghanistan und die Türkei
das öffnet natürlich illegaler Migration
Tür und Torwart die Balkanroute hat sich
auch insoweit verändert als dass die
Österreicher eine ungarischen Grenze
kontrollieren und die migrationsbewegung
über die Slowakei Nacht Tschechien und
danach Deutschland gehen und wir sagen
es immer wieder wir brauchen
stationäre Grenzkontrollen und das
temporär denn aktuell reden wir nur von
Fahndungen und dementsprechend auch von
sogenannten dunkelfeldern und das wäre
relativ einfach der
bundesinnenministerin müsste nur eine
Notifizierung beim Europäischen Rat
Anzeigen sie muss es nicht mal
genehmigen lassen und wir können seriöse
sicherheitspolitische Maßnahmen
betreiben die den Menschen die zu uns
kommt hilft die aber auch uns im
rechtsstaatlichen Verfahren helfen und
mir ist es absolut unerklärlich warum
die Innenministerin die mit absoluter
Handlungsunfähigkeit glänzt zu Lasten
der Sicherheit zu Lasten der Menschen
die zu uns kommen und natürlich auch zu
Lasten der eigenen Bevölkerung Sachsen
warnt jetzt der Innenminister der sagt
der Zustrom sei ja bald kaum noch zu
bewältigen wann ist dieser Zustand
eingetreten wann passiert dieser Zustand
wenn es so weitergeht dass er nicht mehr
bewältigbar ist
also wir sehen natürlich Bilder die
Erinnerungen wecken an 2015 und ich sage
bewusst Erinnerung an 2015 weil wir gar
nicht mehr so weit entfernt davon sind
die Zahlen werden drastisch erhöht
unsere Handlungsfähigkeit tendiert gern
Null und die Sicherheitsbehörden nehmen
ihren gesetzlichen Auftrag war aber ohne
politisch gesetzliche Legitimation wird
schwierig denn gucken Sie sich das an
aktuell auch die Debatte in Dresden die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Bundespolizei machen nichts anderes als
ich bin gesetzlichen Auftrag und sind
sich dann auch noch im Anschluss sicher
von irgendwelchen politischen
Entscheidungsträgern des racial
Profilings bezichtigt zu werden das
führt zu Verunsicherung und kann
natürlich nicht sicherheitspolitisch die
Maßgabe sein und deswegen müssen wir da
jetzt dringend handeln dann sonst werden
wir die Bilder von 2015 Wiedersehen ich
sage immer wieder 2015 ist aktuell der
stand nur die Bilder werden andere sein
und genau das erleben wir gerade das hat
der Innenminister Sachsens ja auch
ziemlich deutlich gemacht sie haben sie
die Situation im Jahr 2015 schon
angesprochen dort hat es auch immer
wieder Übergriffe auf Flüchtlinge
gegeben befürchten sie so etwas auch in
diesem Jahr zumal die wirtschaftliche
Situation ja hier nicht einfacher
geworden ist
ja aus sicherheitsspezifischer Sicht ist
es glaube ich kein Geheimnis dass die
Sicherheitslage aktuell sowieso relativ
präsent und rasant ist
das
radikalisierungspotenzial innerhalb der
Gesellschaft ist nun mal vorhanden und
wenn man jetzt noch illegaler Migration
Tür und Tor öffnet für das natürlich zu
weiteren Unstimmigkeiten und
Verunsicherung gerade bei den
extremistischen Rändern unserer
Bevölkerung und das müssen wir tun
nichts verhindern ich sage auch immer
wieder wenn wir Extremismus bekämpfen
wollen müssen wir allumfassend bekämpfen
und bei den Ursachen anfangen und dazu
gehört nun mal auch
radikalen nicht die Möglichkeit zu
eröffnen bei dem Thema illegale
Migration wieder ihre hetzerische Art
und Weise zu präsentieren und zum
unterschiedlichen Bevölkerungsschichten
auf ihrer Seite zu ziehen dann müssen
wir hellwach sein und das ist Aufgabe
der bundesinnenministerinnen und die hat
sie jetzt auch zu erledigen
sagt Manuel Ostermann vielen herzlichen
Dank Ihnen für das Gespräch
[Musik]